you begin here this morning with reports
that 10 humanitarian corridors will open
in eastern Ukraine today to allow
civilians to escape an expected major
Russian offensive but if the past is any
indicator that plan may not hold
Ukrainian officials say the war is
escalating with no letup in the
targeting of civilians the shock of
Friday's a deadly missile strike in a
crowded railroad station in eastern
Ukraine is still reverberating at least
52 people were killed and dozens hurt in
what Ukrainian president vlodimir
zielinski is calling quote another
Russian war crime he wants a tough
Global Response for the attack Russia
denies responsibility for the Carnage
Deborah patta reports from the Ukrainian
capital of Kiev on what's shaping up to
be the next pivotal battle in the war
with a new Russian general calling the
shots Deborah good morning
good morning the Russians may have lost
the battle for Kiev but they are
redoubling their efforts along the
Eastern front in a bit to seize donbass
Ukrainian officials have been warning
residents to flee the area which is why
so many civilians had gathered at this
rail station in a bid to board trains to
safety before this latest attack
around 4 000 civilians were at the train
station when suddenly it exploded
the strike was not only deadly it was
personal the Russian missile inscribed
with the words for the children
among those killed women the elderly and
the very young this was clearly not a
military Target another entry on the
growing lists of Russian atrocities but
those who've been fighting
russian-backed separatists in the
donbass region say they know what Russia
is capable of senior Lieutenant Starsky
that's his military call sign was there
we spent eight years of learning
to fight specifically against Russians
so they made a big mistake he knew how
they fought yes we knew that by
destroying their Logistics and supplies
they will not be able to quite
efficiently against us and that's
exactly what happened when Russia struck
hostormal airport near Kiev on the first
day of their Invasion Starsky watched
Russian paratroopers spilled onto the
tarmac at least 35 helicopters attempted
to take over the airport I was running
between this and that entrance
firing at those helicopters
Starsky and his unit mounted a fierce
resistance over three days then an
improbable Victory the ukrainians rested
back full control of the airport nobody
really honestly thought Ukraine could do
it at one point you were really the
underdog weren't you surprised
without it the Russians could not set up
an air bridge to bring in crucial
supplies and Manpower the slow troops
down preventing them from advancing on
Kiev and later we realized that actually
what we have done here actually changed
the course of of the war
but the war could take another turn it's
understood the Kremlin has reorganized
its military leadership and a Russian
general with extensive experience in
Syria has been put in charge of
operations in Ukraine for CBS Saturday
morning Deborah padda Kiev